Film Courage: Can you explain why a
movie does not make business sense?
Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker: It's
such an interesting question and an interesting
model when you talk about the the the movie
industry and the film industry and it's
the reason it's interesting is because Hollywood's
always existed in this bubble because it
was always so difficult to be able to create
entertainment and technology wasn't democratized
so no not a lot of people could make entertainment
and so it whenever entertainment was made
especially a film whenever a film was made it was
a very special rare thing and a lot of that defied
the the rules of economics and in the rest of
the world now it seems that in a commoditized
market and there's so much content that when
you look at just the business of filmmaking
it doesn't make a lot of sense to a lot of people
and if you out if you go out and talk to a lot of
investors and the investors a lot of times will
tell you most times they'll tell you that the
economics of the industry just doesn't make sense
for them where you you you put up you put a lot of
money in especially say like a independent film
independent film venture you put a lot of money
in up front you you don't see any return for a
long time there's no sort of incubation model that
you see out of silicon valley or or even just a a
startup business it it's it's a big crazy roll of
the dice you put a lot of money in and you just
hope and pray that a bunch of people show up on
the same weekend and if they show up on the first
two weekends at least maybe you get your money
back but if you if they don't then you lose it all
and it's it's just a high risk it's a high risk
venture especially in a commoditized market where
there's this hyper competition and so it's it
if you look at even other aspects I mean you think
other aspects of the way normal business is done
typically the cost of the cost of production
will drive the retail cost of a of a product
for example and so if you can make a toyota for
ten thousand dollars then you can of hard cost
manufacturing you could sell it for I don't know
twenty two thousand dollars and there you have a
margin in there to make your money but if it if it
costs ninety thousand dollars to make a maserati
then then you have to sell it for two hundred
thousand dollars in order to have your margin
you can't sell it for twenty thousand dollars or
else you're gonna lose money what and that just
makes sense right of course that's the way that's
the way the world works but when in filmmaking
I can make a five thousand dollar paranormal
activity and you could make a three hundred
million dollar avengers movie and someone
still goes pays the same twelve dollars at
the movie theater for the product and that
makes sense to us in the Hollywood bubble
but for the rest of the world that doesn't make a
lot of sense and so so now you're starting to see
you're starting to see a lot of conversation
around the variable pricing and maybe blockbuster
should be 50 movie tickets and paranormal activity
or indie films should be two dollar tickets and
maybe we should scale ticket prices to the cost
of production trying to pull it more in line
with the way normal business works and so it's
really when it when it just comes down to it
especially if you don't have any pre-awareness of
the market the venture to most people is just very
very risky when you especially when you add
in the the cost of prints & advertising and
how much you have to saturate the market
with with marketing just to get people there
it takes the break even in a really crazy way I
think steven soderbergh said a couple years ago
that he predicted the the the death of the
independent film market within five to ten
years because the cost of prints & advertising was
going through the roof at this in this tremendous
in this and that's just tremendous rate
so he said when he's when 15 years ago
you would spend three million dollars to make
a independent film and then you would put an
equal amount in to for prints & advertising with
the which the the distributor would you put an
equal amount in for for the prints & advertising
and then ultimately you work out your breakeven
from that right so uh so usually if you put three
million dollars production three million dollars
prints & advertising what happens is you have
to recoup 50 you recruit 50 cents on the dollar
for the prints & advertising and so you actually
have to make six million dollars to to make back
the three million dollars of the p a because
you split it the the distributor splits it
with the exhibitors right so so that's how it
would work out but now steven soderbergh says
especially with independent films everything's
so competitive and they're so oversaturated and
the market is so commoditized that he says
you if you want to be a blip on the radar
you have to spend at least 35 million dollars of
domestic prints & advertising 35 million dollars
of international prints & advertising just
so people know that you're out there because
there's so much stuff hitting the market all the
time so so let's take a five million dollar movie
for example if you make a movie for five million
dollars and then you spend 35 million dollars
domestic prints & advertising 35 million dollars
of international prints & advertising that's 70
million dollars of prints & advertising which
means you have to make 140 million dollars
to pay back to recoup that right because you
have to split every dollar with the exhibitor
and you recruit 50 cents on the dollar
so you have to make 140 million dollars
plus the 5 million production budget which means
it's a 145 million break even on a 5 million
movie why does that matter this is why it
matters independent filmmakers require and rely
on going to investors and saying will you
give me your money so that I can make my movie
and so just imagine the conversation of going
to an investor and saying I need you to give me
five million dollars of your money so I can
make my movie and all we need to do is make
145 million dollars at the box office and you
get all your money you get all your money back
does that make sense at all it really doesn't
it doesn't to most people now some people have
a they have an appetite for risk and and they and
they want their granddaughter to be able to star
in in in a movie and so they don't care to fund it
and they do it for other reasons vanity projects
things like that but more and more investors
now today it's like that just doesn't make sense
that's why studios love to do a hundred million
dollar movies this is where we've seen the
death of the 20 million dollar film I think is is
because think about like a hundred million dollar
movie put a hundred million dollar production
budget with a hundred million dollars domestic p
a hundred million dollars of international prints
& advertising that's 200 million dollars of p
a you recoup that 50 cents on the dollar which
means you have to make 400 million dollars back
plus the hundred dollar 100 million dollar
production budget that's a 500 million dollar
break even on 100 million dollar movie
so how many 100 million dollar movies
make 500 million dollars as opposed to a 20
million dollar movie making 250 million dollars
right now all of a sudden the 100 million
dollar movie makes maybe more economic sense
than the 20 million dollar movie because the
prints & advertising is thrown out all out of
whack right so so as filmmakers we look at films
through through the lens of of the art and the the
films of the the through the lens of the story
and what we want to achieve and what we want to
say culturally but we failed to put ourselves
in the seat of the of the investor and we and
this is something that i've learned I had to
I'm not a naturally inclined business person
some people are super entrepreneurial and they
get their mba and things like that but I'm not a
I'm not a natural business person but the more
I was I was talking with investors the more they
would and the more they would tell me no the
the I would say why doesn't it make sense to
you yeah and they would explain why this doesn't
make sense and the and when I look at it from the
investors point of view then I'm like wow yeah
that is kind of crazy and that's why we're seeing
independent film investment dry up more and more
because just the economics of the business model
just doesn't compute with the people that have to
fund the whole thing and so you have to understand
that they're coming from it usually by and
large investors independent film investors
aren't filmmakers they're business people right
they're and they've made their money in other
other sectors right so they're looking at at
everything through a completely different frame
than the filmmaker by and large and I
think the more filmmakers can get in tune
with the economics surrounding a film and figure
out how to reorient the economics of the venture
to match the economics of a of a consumer brand
venture or a regular like a silicon valley startup
figure out how do we how do we start to have the
film venture look like one of those other things
and I think if we do that then we're going to see
maybe an uptick in the in the amount of investment
that now goes in to independent films which would
be great for everybody right but it's just going
to take a paradigm shift movies aren't as special
as they used to be because there's so many of them
and so we can't just rely on movies being as
magical in the eyes of investors before we can't
dazzle them with a movie I don't think as much
now we have to we have to make sense to them and
we have to be empathetic to the seat that they sit
in is the film industry the only industry where to
graph out what you talked about and really
go down line by line it doesn't make business
sense or are there other industries where that's
very similar well I think when when you look at
what you typically look for is the difference
between a commoditized business and a
non-commoditized business and these are big ten
dollar words but the difference is commoditization
is where it is is a term where you're in a
market where where you're no longer unique
and because there's so much competition there's
there's hyper competition and over saturation that
has flooded the market most businesses operate and
commoditized markets but businesses that operate
outside of commoditized markets by and large
can set their own rules and they can defy those
odds because what they're doing is so special
and so unique they kind of get a pass because
they're they're creating something that hardly
anybody else is creating until other people start
duplicating that and they become commoditized as
well and there was a time when when the smartphone
was not commoditized and so all of a sudden
apple and steve jobs they they could sort of
set the rules of the game of the economics of the
smartphone and it was up to them not the market
forces but one now I think smartphones have become
commoditized in such a way that that uh that it's
it's a different market than it was 10 15 years
ago or 12 years ago however long smartphones
have been out right so so so I think when when
you're looking for the businesses that operate
outside of a normal paradigm you're looking for
the businesses that that that are just super
unique that that don't have a lot of competition
and when you don't have a lot of competition
you're I'm from kentucky and they and they call
that being in the cat bird seat if you're in an
advantageous situation and entertainment used to
be that and filmmaking used to be that because it
was always too hard too expensive too difficult to
be able to make a movie we we didn't have access
to the camera technology into the post production
technology we didn't have access we had to shoot
on film and film super expensive we didn't have
the digital technology and we definitely didn't
have distribution I mean that the the the
the biggest shift I think for for filmmakers
in in since the invention of the of the the the
talkie is the the internet being a distribution
uh mechanism and because now the app the the the
ability to create and the ability to to distribute
has been democratized to the filmmaker but always
before people didn't have the technology to create
and even if you figured out how to create
you didn't know what to do with it because
you couldn't distribute and so that that that
that that was that was a that was tough and so
the only people that could create movies
were five or six companies in the entire
world that had the the technology and
had the infrastructure for distribution
that could do that so anytime a movie would hit
it would it would be super special and it would
it would be an event and it would be because we
just didn't have a lot of them coming out I mean
think about think about I remember when I was a
kid e.t was in the movie theater for over a year
I believe all is around a year right
just in the theater the theatrical run
now star wars was in there I think 44 weeks
the original star wars movie you look at
something like even back to the future
had like a 35 week run in movie theaters
now you look at avengers in-game which before the
re-release avatar was objectively the the most
successful film of all time avengers in-game
that was in movie theaters what three months
and then it was pushed out there's too much stuff
being being pushed into the system right there's
too much stuff in the pipeline I mean there's
there's there's you talk to show runners they
say 15 years ago there were seven places that
you could sell a one-hour drama now there's
75 places you can sell a one-hour drama right
everybody's everybody's making stuff because the
technology's become democratized and so so it's
it's we the entertainment industry has shifted
from a non-commoditized very special magical like
dazzling glittery thing into the same bucket as
smartphones and potato chips and coffee shops
and everything else that that is commoditized
which is now forcing filmmakers and executives
and studios and everybody that makes this stuff
now we have to re-learn and uh what are the what
are the rules of the game what are the economics
of the game how do we how do we shift this to
better compete in in a commoditized market it's I
think I'm completely convinced that the shift into
a commoditized market is I think for for fans it's
the best thing that's ever happened because we got
as much content as we could we have more content
than we could ever consume with more movies we
could ever watch more tv shows that we could ever
watch more books we could ever read more games we
could ever play more songs we could ever listen to
we can't watch everything on youtube we can't like
there's more tick tock videos than any one person
could ever consume ever which is great for fans
but the commoditized market I think is the single
biggest obstacle facing filmmakers today the the
the the obstacle of access and creation has been
solved right because we got cameras we have we
have we have if you've seen the the the the the
new iphone the iphone 13 that that they announced
like the camera technology and that is absolutely
amazing right even iphone 12 absolutely amazing
what you can do with the camera technology with
that right but even then beyond just the phones
I mean you can go get a red camera a red epic
for for a few thousand dollars and you can rent
a lens for for several hundred dollars over the
weekend and you're able to do that you didn't
used to be able to do that now you can and so
so so that has been solved access and creation
has been solved I think for for for filmmakers
distribution has been solved for filmmakers we
know now how to get our stuff to audiences we
know how to get it in front of people we know how
to build community we go direct to consumer in
about 35 different platforms right in addition
to the sort of the other traditional platforms of
selling to the studios but even if you want to go
direct to consumer we have the ability to do that
the fact that I can I can shoot a video right now
and uh hit a few buttons and upload it to youtube
and instantly it's in six billion people's pockets
is is it is insane and crazy and awesome and
exciting so access has been solved distribution
has been solved but now we've traded those
problems in for a new problem which is how do we
survive in a commoditized market how do we out
punch three million other things that are all
competing against each other somebody said
to me recently they said making a movie today is
is like being a needle in a haystack because you
just release it and there's so much other stuff
I don't actually think it's being a needle on
a haystack I think releasing a movie in today's
market is like being a needle in a needle stack
if you're an if you if you're a needle
in a haystack at least you're unique
but now when you release your horror movie
into the market that's awesome that's such
an amazing achievement right but a thousand
other people are releasing their horror movie
at the same time and you're no longer unique and
now you have all this crazy competition and now
you have to figure out how to out punch your way
not out punch your way from the from the the glut
of horror movies but also all the other movies and
all the other television shows and all the other
books and then don't even get me started about the
tick tock videos in fortnight and things like that
that that pull everybody's competition or it pulls
everybody's eyeballs right and which could create
this hyper competition between all platforms
right so it's it's it's that it's that obstacle
of a commoditized market that I think needs to be
the focus of filmmakers as we go out of 2021 into
2022 and beyond we need to figure out again how
to obviously you need to make a good movie and
you need to tell a great story you need to have
rich characters all that all the craft stuff still
applies I'm not talking about that but now we have
to shift the paradigm of our minds and say what
kind of model and business model and intellectual
property model can I launch that is not going to
survive 1997 paramount pictures Hollywood because
1997 was great but it was a long time ago we don't
live in that market anymore today's market
is a commoditized market and I need my plan
and my model and my approach to survive that
and that's a completely different conversation
what is the business model for filmmakers
today it's a complicated question because
the question could be what should be the
the business model for filmmakers today
or but what is the the the model for
filmmakers today I think still sits
wholly in that traditional model of I got
to go to the studio and I gotta you know
option my option my script and go through the
development process and go through that whole
thing there's the whole traditional side of
the business that's still moving along but now
on the outside of the studio system then you're
you're looking at a different business model
that is is more intellectual property focused and
I think if you if you really study the market and
understand the way the market works it's about
how do you launch and grow intellectual property
and and this is this is not a new concept because
we've known for decades that everything that we
see on tv is always based on a book and even the
the stuff that we know is the most original we
think is the most original stuff we've ever we've
ever uh considered and we we love the originality
of this limited series or this interesting film
98 of the time you trace it back and it's based
on a book and the reason it's based on a book
isn't because hollywood's in love with books it's
because they love the pre-awareness that the books
bring they love the community that's already built
for the book and it skews the risk analysis into
the favor of the filmmaker when they say hey let's
let's take this book and let's make it a movie
it's just a lower risk investment and so so
so intellectual property creation and establishing
intellectual property in the market is has has
always been a thing and but now in the with the
proliferation of other platforms and the the the
democratization of other platforms where normal
people can have access to these other platforms
such as podcast and webtoon and what short stories
on wattpad comic books things like that now the
business model for creators is how to take their
intellectual property and attack the market in
whatever platform they can so that they could
establish a market presence grow the community
of that around that intellectual property actually
get fans and then once they have fans then maybe
down the road they go and shop this thing for
for film and television because when you do that
you can actually have a conversation because you
you have something established in the market and
you have fans and you've established pre-awareness
and I think pre-awareness is is is vital in in
today's market because of the high-risk economics
of of filmmaking because the p a budgets because
the bud the the production budgets are are just
increasing so much I mean you look at you look
at the lord of the rings series on amazon they
spent 250 million dollars just for the rights and
then they spent 450 million dollars in production
for one season of tv and so you're spending three
quarters of a billion dollars on a season of
television and so they're not going to do that
with something that hasn't been established in the
market the only reason they're comfortable with
with spending three quarters of a billion
dollars is because lord of the rings
is an established intellectual property in
the market and that and there's a legion of
tolkien fans and they've tested the the previous
the hobbit movies and lord of the rings movies
and it's been around for a zillion years and all
of a sudden it skews the risk analysis into the
favor of of the studio they said I think we can do
it I mean you look at the foundation series that's
coming out on on apple that apple's releasing and
that that that was a series of books that's been
around forever and a lot of people maybe won't
know that and think oh this is just original
filmmaking now it's established i.p in the market
but used to europe the only way you can do that
is through a book but now like I said you can you
can do that in a variety of different ways and so
one of the most option things in Hollywood right
now are podcasts podcasts are wildly popular as
far as being optioned and you look at what amazon
did with homecoming not beyonce homecoming but
the other homecoming with julia roberts the the
the drama series and that was a podcast you look
at something like night failed it was a podcast
you look at what hbo max they they greenlit the
calm app tv show I don't know if anybody you're
familiar with the comm app the comm app's been a
top 10 app in the app store for the last 10 years
the meditation app it's just a meditation app for
that promotes the proposed mental health and keeps
in makes you calm and helps you meditate and hbo
max just green lit a tv show based on the app
which makes no sense other than there's a brand
there and there's a community there and there's
pre-awareness in the market they'll hire a writer
and they'll hire producers and they'll hire talent
that'll make it work but what they were looking
for is is there the pre-awareness in the market
and you see something with angry birds angry
birds launched into the market not as the animated
films launched in the market as a mobile game and
so I think that is the new business model for
creators is how do I how do I not wait for
netflix or amazon or universal pictures
or disney to to give me permission
to make my dreams come true I don't I don't want
to wait for netflix to give me permission to tell
the story that's in my heart it it it you'll be
waiting forever right and and you'll be deceived
by the fact that there are some people that
netflix does come and make their dreams come
true and they give them the big giant check but
for every one person that's waiting for that that
it actually works for there's there's a hundred
thousand people hundred thousand filmmakers that
that never get that break and it's not because
they're less talented it's just because it's
a it's a hard industry and it's competitive and
there's a lot of super talented people out there
and it's tough to be able and the line around
netflix is 10 blocks long figuratively speaking
with people that want to get in netflix right so
so it's it people are waiting for these studios
to give them permission to to follow their heart
and tell their story when I say that's that's cool
but don't wait or at least while you're waiting
attack the market while you're waiting launch
your intellectual property in the 10 or 15
or 20 ways that we have at your fingertips
at all time that you can do for very little or
zero money like a podcast you can you can take
you can take your iphone and you can download
anchor an anchor is is a free app on the app store
that will allow you to hold up the phone to your
ear and it records your podcast in just into the
phone and then it distr you can put bumper music
and you can edit it and then it distributes it
into the the apple podcast store and it puts it
on spotify all completely for free and then you
can use the the distribution platforms and social
media and things like that to to get it in front
of people start building your audience and you
can actually tell the story that you want to tell
while you're waiting on netflix but the trick is
then if you actually grow the community of people
that that love your podcast love your story and
are engaging with your brand you've increased
your chances from hearing from netflix because
you've actually created pre-awareness the market
right and you you accelerate I mean I there was
there was a there was an intellectual property
that I had uh we we we sold we sold to fox it
languished in development when the turnaround
we got it back and we had played that game for
seven years trying to shop it finally got it
shopped when the turnaround got it back seven
years and I thought what would have happened
if I would we would have been running a podcast
the entire time what would have been what would
have happened if I would have had comic books
in the market and release self-published novels
into the market we wouldn't when it goes in the
turnaround we wouldn't be at zero again we would
have had fans and we would have had a brand and
we would have had intellectual property the film
and television wouldn't have worked the way we
wanted it to work and then we'd have to kind
of reorganize that but at least we would have
done some other things and attack the market
in a way and not just wait for a giant studio to
give me a giant ed mcmahon check and say I give
you permission to tell the story that you've
always wanted to tell and it's so so I'm very
very bullish on encouraging filmmakers don't
wait launch launch launch use all the stuff that
we have all the tools in the toolbox to launch
the intellectual property if uh people that can
produce music work with them to maybe tell a story
through a song and launch that if how to write a
short story launch launch that if how to do a
podcast do it that way do a web tune do do do
something and one it helps you not be frustrated
as you wait to hear back from an agent and sending
out query letters and the whole game that we all
know which is I'm not saying that's bad I'm saying
okay let's do that but while we do that let's
do some other things so you're not just sitting
around waiting to hear back from people you're
actually doing something right which keeps you
it just keeps you happy as a storyteller to be
able to tell your stories I mean I personally
I found myself years ago as a writer the things
the things that I wrote most were pitch decks I
found myself writing more pitch decks than I were
that I did scripts and that was disconcerting to
me right because that's sort of what you kind of
fall into in Hollywood is this crazy game of just
trying to like hustle something and and you're
doing a lot less creating and just a lot more
pitching right and so so there's there's a I
think there's an artistic and a soulful benefit
to launching intellectual property in the market
just satisfies you as you wait for the the big
guys to come and make your dreams come true but
then there's also a legal benefit to it and so
I consider myself a recovering lawyer I started
my career as a lawyer uh and almost completely
recovered as a lawyer but from a legal perspective
if you can establish an intellectual property in
the market there's a lot greater chance of you
getting a better deal on the back end if and when
the studio comes and wants to participate in into
a feature film if you just write a spec script and
you go and like like like filmmakers do and like
writers do and you go sell that spec script and
it's not based on any pre-existing intellectual
property that is it's just an original idea and
you sell you settle inspect say you get on the
blacklist and they snatch it off the blacklist and
they they they give you a deal that's awesome it's
it's it's by and large a wholesale acquisition
it's we're taking the whole bucket of rights and
we'll give you a check that's a high five handoff
that you you go off and we'll take this and
we'll go and make this movie but they have all
the rights to every platform ever created and here
forever two will be created until the end of time
there's all those big lawyerly clauses in there
they own everything right they take the whole deal
theoretically they give you a check to make you
feel better about that right which sometimes that
makes you feel better other times it doesn't
but if you say publish a book self-publish a
book and and that book sells and you're able
to then get that to be turned into a movie
the deal that is then done is a different deal
it's then you have what's called a split rights
deal where they come and license the right to
adapt the book into movie right so they take
the film and television rights right but it's a
license deal for the film the television rights
and you maintain your other intellectual property
rights video game comic books merchant things like
other things that you want to create right and
which is much better in success of the movie
right or the tv show or whatever they do then
all these other rights become more valuable and
you've retained them simply because you were able
to establish the IP [aka Intellecutal Property]in
the market and you didn't you didn't go to
the studios first right so so even if you
don't want to talk about the the the sort of
the creative benefits of attacking the market
and being aggressive with the IP [aka Intellecutal
Property] and not waiting right and being passive
as as your fake lawyer as for that that I would
give you this this legal advice never just sell
a spectrum to a studio it's crazy just publish it
self-publish it as a book first now ten years ago
before you could really self-publish or there
wasn't really podcast and there weren't really
these other things then what what are you supposed
to do the only thing you could do is is just sell
it directly to a studio because not not a lot
of other other options right now there are so
many options it's it makes it just doesn't make
a lot of sense to be able to go to them first
you're just you're just you're misappropriating
and losing sight of the broader opportunity of
your intellectual property so so I think the new
business model for creators is a business model
to attack the market with intellectual property
attack the market with intellectual property
and when you when you generate the pre-awareness
of the community it's going to create residual
benefits that is that are not only going to
make you more attractive to the studios but
it's actually going to help you retain more and
control more of the intellectual property moving
forward and from what I understand about this new
netflix series made yeah with margaret quality
it started as an article a woman who
was in a homeless shelter with her child
she was cleaning houses and she kind of wrote this
thing about hey what people don't know about what
I know about you from cleaning your house and
that took off and then she did this book and
then and now and now we have this this show coming
up sure I'm looking forward to seeing it and again
that was someone that was always wanted to be
a writer had a lot of tragic things happen and
decided to hunker down and sort of make the best
of it and look at now it's sure that that's a rags
to which the story right there and if she would
have just written that as a spec script and then
just started shopping that around I think we we
would well we wouldn't be having this conversation
today because because it would have gotten it
would be languishing in the crazy game that is
the spec world of Hollywood right she she was able
to take this and then launch it in a different way
let's write the article let's let's do it let's
launch it in a different form let's then publish
the book let's let's do it as a blog let's do
something else right and then we we grow awareness
we grow the pre-awareness we we've we've actually
established the intellectual property in the
market and then guess what especially when it
becomes popular then then then the studios want
to get involved and that deal and I'm not privy
to the the specifics of the deal but I would
guarantee that that deal that was made for that
particular that particular intellectual property
is a better deal than she would have got if she
would have written the spec script and tried to
sell that spectre at first I don't think she
would have sold the spec grip to begin with
but in the event that she would have it would
have been a worse deal than what she got now
simply because she was able to establish it
in the market right but see see this is the
interesting thing it's it's a paradigm shift
with with filmmakers typically filmmakers
and screenwriters and listen I include myself
in this umbrella so it we we we want to focus
on filmmaking and screenwriting and and we
feel like if I just write my five pages a day
everything's going to work and I don't want
to learn how to do a podcast like that's not
me I don't want to learn how to make a website I
don't want to I don't want to write short stories
I'm a screenwriter right and I wish
I wish that person would have been
born in 1978 and then was able to be able
to operate in late 80s 90s Hollywood because
because it was just as a different market you
could kind of specialize like that but but it's
just it's a different market and there's this
this there's this hesitancy for lack of a better
word if I say that euphemistically there's this
hesitancy to broaden your scope of creative to
be able to launch an intellectual property in the
market you feel like you're you're doing something
that's less than screenwriting you're lowering
yourself to do a short story you're lowering
yourself to do a podcast there's this this this
this artistic judgment and you feel like you you
and maybe you just judge yourself of like man
that this means that I'm if I was good enough
i'd be able to sell this thing right and you judge
yourself for it and you shouldn't judge yourself
for that you it's it's it there's too much
stuff out there and it's way too competitive and
I think if if creators and filmmakers and
screenwriters if they have the mind of a of
an entrepreneur who's who's launching a consumer
brand you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
approach this whole thing differently because you
talk to any entrepreneur that that says I'm gonna
start a pizza shop right and I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna open the pizza shop and it's gonna be
great because I have this family recipe of pizza
i've been working on like they are forced to learn
a hundred new skills in order to launch that
pizza shop right you never hear somebody say
I want to launch my pizza shop with my family
recipe of pizza and I'm only going to focus on
making the pizza I'm not going to learn how to do
payroll I'm not going to learn how to hire front
of house back house I'm not going to learn how
to order I'm not going to learn about management
I'm not going to learn how to do the register I'm
not going to learn about anything else other than
pizza and that's it I'm just going to focus on my
pizza and as long as I make good pizza everything
will fall into place odds are that pizza shop will
never open right because of course entrepreneurs
know I want to do a pizza shop I know how to
make a good pizza okay I still have to learn
how to run the register and I still have to learn
how to market the right way and I still have to
learn how to how how to manage my staff and I
still have to learn how to order all the food
from the wholesalers and things like that you you
it you're forced into figuring out five or six
new things that you've never figured out before
and that's just part of being an entrepreneur
and every entrepreneur will tell you that like
you have to you're forced to learn 100 new things
what are those 10 new things that we need
to learn as screenwriters and filmmakers
what are the 20 new things that that that we
can learn as creators that can help us launch
the intellectual property and here's the good part
here's the here's the punch line that I think is
the greatest punch line of all time it's all there
on the internet for free youtube is the greatest
educational platform in the history of mankind
if I want to figure out how to change a 1987
volvo station wagons carburetor there's probably
a youtube video that's going to walk me through it
we can go to go to youtube go to google and say
how do I how do I create a podcast and there's
17 articles instantly or 17 videos that pop up
you can go to linkedin learning and or or you
can go to whatever like a resource that you want
to use and you can take the 7 to 10 to 27 hours
to figure it out and not that you can connect with
people that know how to do it I had a buddy who
he won the nichols fellowship as a screenwriter
right which is a big deal nicholas is is a very
competitive screenwriting competition he won
the nichols fellowship he he pitched a movie
to paramount pictures as a result of winning the
the the nichols fellowship he pitched the script
to paramount paramount said it was too risky
because it wasn't established in the marketplace
and they said we want you to go and create a comic
book and launch it as a comic book and if you sell
10 000 copies of that comic book come
back to us and we'll make your movie
so he walked out of that meeting super bummed
not just because they didn't make the movie but
they said make a comic book and guess what he was
a screenwriter he didn't know how to make a comic
book right which if this was 1992 that would have
been a big bummer but because it was 2017 he was
able to go home open up the laptop google how do
I make a comic book and he started reading and
he started finding out where the artist hung out
online in the artist communities and art station
and deviantart and things like that he he's
he's learned the production workflow the cost
of making a comic book how they were
distributed he just started researching
and he connected with an artist in a like
estonia or some europe eastern european country
that that that he they decided to collaborate
on something they they scraped and put one issue
of a comic book together took him months they
put an issue of one issue of a comic together
and they they distributed it digitally on amazon
and made enough money from it to make an issue too
and then they made enough money on it to make an
issue three and then they made enough money on it
to make it issue four and then after issue four
guess what happened they got picked up by a small
independent publisher that said we'll pay for
the publishing of it right so they did issue five
and then after issue five they're putting it all
together as a trade paperback all five issues
together and now four years later he's right on
the verge of his 10 000 unit cell right and he
says houston guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
go back to paramount pictures and tell them to
make my movie because I have to hit the ten
thousand dollar or the ten thousand sale mark
right but guess what I'm not going to stop selling
the comic book why because it's an extra source of
revenue for me and I have a community of fans that
love this stuff right so why would I stop and so
now he self-identifies as not just a screenwriter
but he's a screenwriter slash comic book creator
right he's there's there's this there's this this
term called polymath right people that are good
at multiple things and we typically lawed people
in entertainment that can do more right beyonce
can sing and she can dance and j lo can act and
sing and dance and we always say all these people
are amazing they're entrepreneurs and actors and
singers and creators and we love that about people
we need to start looking at ourselves as that
because we have the ability to do that and because
all the tools are in front of us so I think that's
the model that we have to hit is is being willing
to have that mindset shift of I need to learn
some more I need to broaden my own skill set
right and but when I do it's going to open
up a no new world for me because I'm able to
establish my p my intellectual property in the
market why don't we see new ideas in Hollywood
I think it's because of risk I think
when you look at the risk analysis of
feature films or or television the the there's
a hesitancy of taking a chance on a new idea
you have to you have to think about Hollywood as
not in a vacuum where you there's all these middle
managers in Hollywood they're all executives
right and there's there's there's a hundred
people that that are all involved in everything in
the decision of what to make and what not to make
and by and large people don't make those decisions
based on what is the what's going to propel the
industry forward creatively and what's going to
be what what does the artistic integrity of the
of the industry need and like they're not asking
those questions they're asking the questions of
what can I do not to get fired from my job
and if it's a lot easier for these executives
to to say no to something that could potentially
be risky than to say yes to something that could
be potentially risky and it not work out and all
of a sudden they get the blame because they took
the risk I mean if I'm if I'm a studio executive
and I have two scripts in front of me and one is
this really hip interesting progressive edgy
uh script that really pushes boundaries in a
really interesting way that's a lot of creative uh
edgy interesting things and then I have the reboot
of the brady bunch as a feature film starring
vince vaughn as greg brady which actually sounds
sounds kind of good but yeah but if I have that in
front of me and that's like solidly mediocre right
but if I have those two things in front of me the
most artistically interesting choice then is the
new idea let's let's promote new ideas let's not
go back to well in the brady bunch right but 99
times out of 100 what's going to happen is going
to be we're going to make the brady bunch not
because we think the brady bunch is going to be
better or one it has pre-awareness in the market
right so it has a community of people that already
know what the brady bunch is even if you don't
haven't seen an episode of the brady bunch odds
are people have heard of brady bunch and so
there's this market awareness that that shifts the
risk and they think it's a safer bet and because
it's the safer bet they think if I push my chips
in on the brady bunch and it gets made and it
doesn't do as well as we think I still be able to
keep my job because I made the safe decision but
if I go all in on on a completely original idea
and that that is the more artistically interesting
idea and it doesn't work guess what who's on the
chopping block me for making the bad call right
and listen it may not be my fault maybe other
people's fault everybody's kind of shifting the
blame everybody wants to blame somebody in
in and especially on the executive level it
it's you could only lose 50 million dollars in
somebody else's money so many times before they
don't give you 50 million dollars to lose anymore
right and so it's tough that decision to green
light or not the green light but that's not made
in a vacuum they they sit there and say how do I
how do I keep my nice six-figure salary with
my premium health insurance and how do I keep
my kids in private school and how do I keep my
wife not having to work and do the things that
she likes to do and how do I keep my house
and my gated community and how do I keep
the the two cars that I have and like what are the
decisions that can preserve that and I'm going to
do those because then if I do those long enough
eventually my boss will retire and maybe I get
it promoted and then and that becomes that game
and listen I'm not even criticizing those people
for doing that maybe I do that in the same if I'm
in the same situation I have kids I got a house
I got a wife I got dogs I got things right so and
I don't want to get fired we need health insurance
like there's all these other pressures that come
in but if you if you now if you now look at the
entire industry as an industry that is motivated
not on artistic integrity but how do I keep my job
that really clues you in of why we don't see a
lot of new stuff that's why we see reboots that's
and listen largely reboots don't work we saw that
with female ghostbusters we saw that with the new
terminator movie we saw that we've seen that
every now and then they work right hawaii 5-0
worked I think uh the there's some that that 21
jump street I think worked actually the times you
actually see it work I think it's when you shift
platform if it was originally a movie then they
turn it into a tv show or originally a tv show and
they turn it into a film that usually works more
than film the film or show to show typically
just as an anecdotal observation but it's uh
largely reboots don't work that well in the
industry just look at the numbers so why do
they do it it's because it's the safer bet but
even though we know it's not a safe bet it looks
like the safer bet so when people come to blame
somebody I can say well no everybody knew the
brady bunch it's not my fault it's vince vaughn's
fault it's the director's fault somebody else's
fault but mine right so then I get it stay in my
gated community I mean it's really interesting
I mean look at the the executives I was I was
talking to the with the president of he had a
really interesting comment he said executives they
they live in the gated communities and then they
leave their gated communities and drive through
the gate into the lot and then work and then they
drive back to their gated communities and
never go east of robertson right and they
live in this weird little bubble that breeds
a different mentality than than the consumer
or the audience or when we're saying why don't we
have any more ideas it's not our money on the line
right it's easy to say there should be new ideas
we shouldn't make so many superhero movies it's
not our money like it's easy it's easy to say that
if you're not if it's if it was your 50 million or
100 million dollars that you're actually putting
on the line maybe that conversation changes right
because now you're like maybe I don't want to take
the risk on the progressively interesting edgy
psychological thriller that doesn't
have any pre-awareness in the market
maybe it will end up being one of the coolest
most artistic films that we've seen in the last 10
years but we've all seen movies like that not be
financial successes this is when this is how they
turn in the cult classics right and we see movies
and we're like how did that how did that not work
why doesn't everybody see this and there's there's
a hundred reasons why a thousand reasons why
great films aren't commercial successes
and not being a commercial success doesn't
not make you a great film artistically of course
right but when it's your money on the line
it's a different story right and so and so you
have to and if and when it's your job on the line
when you're spending somebody else's when it's
your job to spend someone else's money which puts
your job on the line the calculation changes right
I think it's that's a I had I had a situation
where I pitched a I pitched a tv show to a studio
and they were looking for content for their their
digital extension of their of their network and
they they told me what they were looking for
I pitched this idea the the the to a producer
had a had a pod deal with the network and he said
this is perfect I love it this is exactly what
we're looking for and I'm super excited because I
think oh well this this deal's done this is great
and he said what what book is this based off of
and I said oh it's not based off a book
it's an original idea and his whole body
language changed he like slumped down and
says oh yeah it needs to be based on a book
and I and I said no it doesn't because you
love it and you think it's perfect and it's
exactly what you need so we're good right
he said no needs to be based on a book so
is it possible that we could find a book that
already exists that is kind of like the idea
we can option that book and then
say this idea is based on that book
and I said that's this is the stupidest
conversation i've ever had with anybody
in my whole life you said it's perfect you
said it's exactly what you're looking for
you love it what's the problem and he said houston
I do love it is exactly what I'm looking for is
this exactly what we need but the fact of the
matter is I am not going to take something to my
boss that's not based on a book because I don't
want to put my job on the line for you that's
exactly what he told me and I said I appreciate
your honesty I really honestly did like appreciate
like that insight I got it I expected this guy
to go out on a on a limb stick his neck out
for an idea and an intellectual property that that
wasn't established in the marketplace didn't have
any community built around it didn't have any
market presence it was risky and I expected him
to assume my risk which puts his job on the line
and he didn't what he didn't feel comfortable with
that because he wanted to he didn't care about
the art I'm gonna say he didn't care about the art
he didn't just care about the art I mean of course
he wanted to make a good show right but there was
other considerations that were very practical he
wanted to keep his job and we forget that we we
forget that that in the music industry the a r
executives there's a lot of undiscovered talent
that may be better than other people but all of a
sudden I'm gonna sign the tick tock star that is
much worse than this undiscovered talent because
the tick tock star has 12 million people that
follow the tick tock talk star on tick tock
therefore if the tick tock star washes out
it's not my fault because I took the safe bet
rather than I go out and pluck the undiscovered
dude from iowa that doesn't have any following
he washes out guess what it's on me because I
took the risk I didn't I took a risk and I lost
and so the calculation changes then this is why
this is why somebody like like jake paul or logan
paul they they can go out and they can they can
fight uh these these these named boxers they
can go out and fight floyd mayweather I mean
did logan paul fight floyd mayweather because he's
the the the best most deserving boxer in the world
no he did it like he was able to do that because
it was a safe bet like he had pre-awareness in the
market and then just made sense and so like it
just that's just the the the fact of the matter
of it right like it's just jake paul can go and
write a script and sell that script to a major
studio faster than 99 of independent screenwriters
in Hollywood right now that are 19 000 times more
talented than jake paul no offense to jake paul he
may be a closet screenwriter I'm not sure I don't
think he is but you get what I'm saying is is it's
not because he's better it's because he's safer
and the executives know that the executives
know that and they can they don't think that
jake paul will write better stuff but they think
if they bet on jake paul rather than you if jake
paul doesn't work they can keep their job so we
always as creators as filmmakers we always have
to understand the business of the business
and understand the very human calculation
that is going on in the executive level or the
investment level or the people that are behind
the desk it's not these decisions aren't made
in a vacuum it's not just what's going to make
the best movie unfortunately that's not
the case anymore right maybe maybe it was
back in 1977 maybe it was a different mentality
that went into executives but today's executives
it's a high-stakes high-pressure environment
and there's there's real careers on the line
there's real families that rely on real
salaries and we just think we just think
well as long as our concept's right and as long
as our three-act structure works and as long as
our character development's right then if if if
I if I am able to execute the art the right way
then then they should make my idea and just it's
just and then you get frustrated when they don't
and then you see crappy movies that are released
that are reboots and you're like oh where's the
original ideas just a more complicated very human
calculation that's going on that's different than
the calculation you think is going on well and
people are voting with their dollars someone's
seeing it whether they're the ones that are also
leaving a gated community to go into the gated
parking lot at the local cineplex
someone's buying these tickets and so
I whether they whether they just are checking
their phone the entire time or not and they're
not really they're just going to appease their
their kids or their friends is to not to be known
right now but so someone is seeing these things
sure that's the hard part and the ones that these
art house films or the these very unique edgy
indie dramas whatever unfortunately the their
people aren't always voting with their dollars
to show that they love that stuff sure and listen
and you're right the market decides the market
decides what it likes and what it isn't like and
yeah and that's the way normal business works
that's the way the world works the market decides
what works and what doesn't and we can't just sit
back and make value judgments and say well my my
movie was better than that well if the market has
decided that it's not now artistically speaking
that's maybe a different consideration this is
this is the the difference between the oscars
and the people's choice awards or the just look
at the box office like really I mean they don't
give out the oscars just based the best picture
could be what was the highest achieving box
office picture of the year they don't do that they
look at they look at the art and there's artistic
achievement that's the focus of the oscars but
really the the the the re the regular the regular
audience member again I'm from kentucky we I don't
I'm not from the coast and now that i've been on
the coast for 15 years I realize just it's a
different mentality when you're in Hollywood
people seen all the oscar movies and they've seen
all the all the the streaming shows and all the
deep cuts and they can but you go you go to middle
america you go to wyoming you go to kentucky
go to ohio go to georgia it's it's it's there
people don't people don't know the directors they
don't know the dps and they don't know all the
the deep cut indie films and they haven't seen
david lynch's third movie he made out of film
school and like they like but when you live in
the bubble of Hollywood maybe new york right you
convince yourself that everybody thinks this way
and you start making you start making stuff for
people in the bubble right listen not saying
that you just have to make so the quote-unquote
studio crap the quote-unquote big commercial high
concept film you have to make superheroes all
the time there there are there is room for art
but I think ultimately you need to figure out how
to marry art and commerciality that's the there's
an intersection that can happen and when that
happens that's that's magic I I i it never never
ceases to surprise me of how many filmmakers
fight for the right to be a starving artist
and they they they find pride in it
and I just I can never understand it
I would much rather than be well-fed artists still
be an artist but figure out how to operate in a
commercial environment where the audience will
vote with their dollars I feel like we have to
find that intersection something like a quiet
place was was I think in a good example of
that it was I thought it was a very well made
interesting artistic very very different choice
of of how to do a monster movie and very almost
risky in a way but it had commercial sensibility
and it worked and you look at something like ted
lasso I think ted lasso I feel like is is is a
really interesting commercial success that isn't
game of thrones right like it but at the same
time isn't the office or like I feel like this
it's an interesting it's an interesting thing
if you look at what's going on in the emmys the
the people that are cleaning up the enemies it
was the crown and the uh queen's gambit right
the queen gambit was a huge commercial success
but at the same time I think was a a a wild
artistic success as well I feel like it felt fit
that intersection and I feel like that's what
a lot of independent filmmakers struggle with
is finding that intersection but because they they
they they need to they need to think outside the
bubble and listen ultimately you got you got to
make what's in your heart and make what drives you
and sustains you right and so but it's it becomes
difficult when you're making stuff that that that
the market doesn't bear right and if you're and if
you're happy with that and you're fine with that
muscle top that's great but ultimately I feel
like we need to figure out that intersection
and if you can again it goes back to that
pre-awareness conversation if you can figure out
how to take that interesting super artistic edgy
intellectual property if that people don't want to
touch because it's it's too risky if you're able
to establish that in the market in three or four
different ways or even one way like you establish
it as a podcast and it pops to the podcast and
now a hundred thousand people subscribe to that
podcast guess what it's the same edgy progressive
artistic character drama idea but now all of
a sudden the studios are going to now be more
apt to take a a take a gamble on that original
idea because you were able to establish in the
marketplace first right so I think that approach
really really benefits people that don't just
want to make superhero movies or marvel movies
or zombie movies or vampire movies or whatever
the big genre flicks or whatever it is they want
to do some different artistic interesting things
even more these people have to embrace all the
tools in the toolbox they have to figure out how
to establish in the marketplace let's let's prove
the audience and once we can prove the audience
then all of a sudden these people that were that
were nervous about taking taking a flyer on it
are are going to be a lot less nervous because
they see that you've proven yourself in the
marketplace I had an investor that said that that
told me every single movie that is pitched to him
he he he has the filmmakers go he said he'll
he'll invest if he decides to invest he will
only invest 80 percent and it's 80 finishing
funds and he makes the filmmakers go and raise
20 the first 20 of the budget on kickstarter
right and it's it's one I think he's tested the
horsepower of the filmmaker but really what he's
looking for is you need to prove that there's a
market you need to prove to me that there are
people that will actually get behind this thing
and if those people that actually get behind
this thing guess what okay cool how come with the
the other eighty percent but you gotta you gotta
generate the market first right and so so I think
if you are one of the filmmakers that have the
edgier non-commercial idea then you have to figure
out a way to get that story and that intellectual
property to as many people as you can aggregate
the data and the analytics of the audience and
then use that to soften the risk analysis that
was was was probably well against you that was
working against you but now you can shift that
now to potentially depending on the success
to actually working for you in a great way
and two with with the queen's gambit as as sort
of edgy and artistic as it was walter tevis had
already proven himself with the hustler sure
and and then it's the man who fell from earth
and I'm not sure how all that fared but so there
were there was a succession of of of successes
you could call it and so if it had just been
an obscure screenwriter who wrote the exact
same thing would they have taken a chance on it
as amazing as it was well this is this is what
they tell you when you go when you go shop shop
a a script that's non unbranded content right
they'll say they'll say you need to go package
this you need to find attachments to this and you
need to go find an actor that will say i'll act in
this or you need to find a director that says i'll
direct this or producer that says i'll produce
this and if you get the attachments involved
now all of a sudden they may take a chance on
an original idea that's unbranded that's not
based on anything else because they're getting
the pre-awareness from the talent rather than
the intellectual property right so and so yeah if
you can get if you can get uh julia roberts to say
hey I'm in or get michael b jordan said i'll i'll
i'll be in that that'd be great or you get uh
the rock to say i'll i'll i'll produce it and
star in it right if you can get that then the
game changes for you the problem with that the
practical problem with that is it's difficult to
get attachments it's hard talk to any agents and
like the agents will tell you they'll they'll say
that their clients have scripts they're the the
people they rep they have a stack of script that's
taller than my seven-year-old that they're waiting
for them to read to decide what to attach to
and then that's the ones that actually get to
them right but it's how do you get to these people
right how do you how do you like for the for
the the mere mortal filmmaker how do you get
to michael b jordan how do you get your script to
michael b jordan especially if you're unrep now
if you're if you have a manager or an agent then
then you expect your agent to figure out how to
connect with their agent and make the submission
and things like that but especially if you're
if you're unwrapped it's like it's it's in your
impossibility unless you see him at a club and you
get in the conversation or or or your your sister
is friends with his cousin and one of those weird
gotta know people to know people type of thing
right that Hollywood just works with with in a lot
of ways but it's hard to get those attachments I
had a a buddy who was a professional house sitter
for celebrities when they go out of town like
he's licensed and bonded as a as a as a house
sitter which is god bless america that that can
even be a thing but so he goes out and he uh these
celebrities go to town he'll stay at their house
feed their dogs feed their parent things like that
and then and then there's somebody there in case
they get robbed or they think they won't get
robbed if somebody's in the house so but he was
telling me that he was at he was he was staying at
at a at an actor's house who was an a-list actor
in the 70s late 70s now is older probably a c-list
actor at this point not doesn't do a lot of
stuff but used to be everybody knows him his
big name right and he and he told me he said he
would receive courier packages of scripts and he
would open them up take the script out open up a
room and throw it in and there was this huge pile
of scripts there that this guy was supposed to be
reading through in order to decide what to attach
to what's going to be your next movie right
and it's just like so frustrating for writers
and because we're writing this stuff and we send
it out and we just we we're we we think okay the
rock's gonna read this and I'm just waiting
for the rock to get back to me and tom hanks
is gonna maybe be in my movie maybe not right
but at the same but now it's it's 150 scripts
before he'll get to your script and who knows
when that is it's a hard game to get attachments
right if you can get attachments great but
I like to now say I'm gonna I'm gonna now
approach intellectual property in a way that
that I'm gonna presume I don't get any bigger
attachments I'm not gonna I'm not gonna not try
to get attachments of course you attempt to get
attachments but I'm gonna presume I don't and so
that if I do it's gravy it's not the entree I'm
not betting on it right and so I'm gonna try to
attack the market build the intellectual property
with pre-awareness as much as I can with the
mindset that i'll never get attachments so that I
can skew the risk analysis myself through the con
the aggregation of the of the audience and then
if jennifer lawrence decides to be in the movie
then even better it's gravy right it's it's the
icing on the cake not the cake itself right but
that shows you the pre-awareness has to come from
somewhere it's either coming from the talent or
it's either coming from the intellectual property
but it has to come from somewhere right unless
this is this is my eternal caveat to that horror
movies horror movies are this really bizarre
exception somebody like jason blum can can can
they can make a horror movie with nobody you've
ever heard of with a director you've never heard
of with a story that's never been been established
in the marketplace and you can still make those
movies and they can still make money at the box
office and horror movies defy all those rules for
whatever reason which is interesting the horror
genre is very specific about that if you come up
with a concept that's great and the visual concept
that goes along with it and figure out like a
wildly creative way to kill people and things like
that then then you can you can still you can still
get that stuff made so so which is great for the
horror for the horror industry everything but the
[ __ ] outside of the horror industry operates on
pre-awareness in a major way I actually like that
idea for a movie that the house sitter and that
the guy goes in and starts reading these scripts
because he's bored he has all this time he's
supposed to stay there and then he starts writing
himself he doesn't take anybody's ideas but he
just starts he says what I want to do a screenplay
and he gets made I love it that would be that
would be awesome yeah you should write that okay
maybe I don't know just establish it in
the morning i'll check with your friends
houston what are your thoughts on Hollywood
reboots what are we doing wrong what are we
doing right I think reboots in general yeah
I'm not I'm not a huge fan of them I think
I in in in large respect people talk about they
ruin my childhood and things like that like we
we have nostalgia about the things that we loved
before but at the same time reboots reintroduce
the story to a new generation that that wouldn't
necessarily go back and watch an older film
and we have to understand that that reality of
it if I I I loved ghostbusters when I was a kid
but I tried to show ghostbusters to my little girl
and it just wasn't jiving with her like she it's
different filmmaking different storytelling styles
in different eras right I mean even even with with
star wars the original star wars she's she just
thinks it's like a weird old movie because the
filmmaking's so different now right and so she
likes the new star wars movies more than the
old star wars movies when I think artistically the
old star wars movies were better but with reboots
I think is there a generation of kids that will
actually go back and watch the old 21 jump street
series probably not should they yeah of course
they should of course yeah but will they
probably not and so that means
there's going to be a generation of
kids that don't know the the 21 jump street story
and so rebooting 21 jump street in a different way
reintroduces the intellectual property to a
new generation so in that regard I I'm i'm
I I'm down with it I like it I think though
what's better is let's figure out how to do
a soft reboot but still extend the story I think
that's the sweet spot and you really look to see
something like what jj abrams did with star
wars with with the force awakens he essentially
rebooted star wars without rebooting star wars
he he technically told the new story but if you
look at the way that movie was structured and
the story and the characters it was basically
a soft reboot of star wars for people that haven't
seen star wars and it basically retold a new hope
just in a very new and different way and but at
the same time for legacy fans it still extended
the story for us so technically it was new stories
for the new story for us didn't ruin our childhood
because they weren't just wiping away the old
and reestablishing the new and that's what fans
don't like about reboots they're saying the thing
that we love before is now no more we're erasing
that from canon and we're we're we're now creating
this new thing and we're going to start here comic
book fans it's referred to as a renumbering when
they they'll say this there's superman 731 issue
731 they'll say we're gonna renumber we're gonna
start over number one which means we're gonna wipe
out the cannon of all the old stuff that's always
painful for fans to do that but that's essentially
what reboots do they say the old hawaii 5.0
is no longer now it's the new hawaii 5.0 and
the fans the old old get surly about that because
they're precious and there's nostalgia and there's
memories attached to it and things like that even
though technically is the new stuff better because
there's better filmmaking techniques and better
technology maybe probably that's that's that's a
subjective call right but I think the sweet spot
is let's figure out how to do soft reboot reboots
that ex that extend for legacy audience but
create a new entry point in for a new audience
find that that intersection if the you look at
what they're doing with the ghostbusters and
my little girl didn't like the old the old
ghostbusters then the female ghostbusters
that when that dropped that just didn't
work because ghostbusters fans rejected it
because they're saying wait a minute like those
aren't my ghostbusters I love dan aykroyd and I
love I love my ghostbusters where's egon and all
that like that's the kind of nerdy stuff that
that fans get into now there are there's also the
layer of the the misogynistic these are women and
we didn't like that there's that whole sort of
political angle to it but I think a large degree
legacy ghostbusters fans just just didn't
like their their ghostbusters being deleted
for new ghostbusters I think if they were
if it was all men it probably wouldn't
have worked either right may have been a
different commentary around it listen and
of course I'm not denying the fact that there
were people that were just misogynistic jerks
about the whole thing of course there was that I
don't know if that was the bulk of it I think it
just wouldn't work regardless because that movie
is so precious to so many people that but now
it's a whole different conversation with the
new ghostbusters movies that's coming out which
effectively is a is a reboot of ghostbusters
for people who have never seen ghostbusters
but it still extends ghostbusters for people that
have seen ghostbusters the legacy audience right
and so you you have to try to find that sweet
spot I think of of how do we extend and continue
rather than stop delete and then restart right and
so that's I think that's what we that I think is
a better way forward than just the the the hard
reboot and maybe there's a there's a different
term for it but I think from a from a you can't
you have to you have to get a buy-in from a
legacy audience especially something like iconic
iconic like like like ghostbusters right that
has a community a fan community around it maybe
there wasn't a fan community around hawaii five-o
or maybe maybe there was maybe there was I'm not
sure but things that have actual fan community
around it I think I really feel like you
have to you have to you have to continue
rather than just restart and delete everything
that's old they're they're uh facing this with
the reboot of the pirates of the caribbean
franchise and which is crazy they're already
talking about rebooting pirates of the caribbean
I feel like it was just out five minutes ago but
there it's going to be a hard reboot which means
they're just going to start over and start telling
different stories with a new jack sparrow and
and and that's that's that for all the fans that
love johnny depp as jack sparrow and all those
old movies then then that's going to be a hard
tough pill to swallow to say all this stuff that
I love doesn't count anymore and because now it's
this new thing and there's going to be a division
in the fandom you can't divide fandom like that
and expect to be a success and so so so yeah I'm
not ideal ideolo ideologically against reboots
of like all reboots are terrible I think
some are smart and some reintroduce
fans to new stuff like what if they would I
ever want them to reboot the princess bride
no right but do do kids today go back and
watch the princess bride will they ever maybe
I don't know like that's the that's that's the
calculation right but I think it would be better
to do the princess bride now so many years later
that extends the original but still is a soft
entry point for new fans but still serves the
legacy audience how do we how do we find that
balance I'm not saying it's easy jj abrams did it
with force awakens did it really well but and I
think the ghostbusters is doing that really well
but it's not easy it's a balancing act but I feel
like in today's fandom-driven market you gotta
find that balance do you still love star wars now
the same way you did when you first saw it in the
theater or wherever you were absolutely I consider
myself just a huge star wars fan I I i love star
wars I am wildly not objective about star wars
and it's interesting from a I I try to be
objective about star wars but I find myself
loving it anyway and I I go back and I look
at star wars and I I read I recently read
the script of episode one a phantom menace and
may have been the worst script i've ever read
like just it's just it's just a really bad script
in my opinion it was just terri it's terrible
I still love the movie I still love the movie and
it's interesting I think you look at some artistic
decisions how you watch black swan and then you
see how the george lucas turned natalie portman
into a bad actress like how did that even like you
and mcgregor liam neeson and natalie portman how
do you turn those people into and samuel jackson
how do you how do you turn them into bad actors
that are wooden and stiff like that's that's hard
to do he he did that they like they weren't that
great think of the artistic choice of the second
death star in in return of the jedi I was thinking
about that the other day you have the death
star in in the first movie and then you get
to the third movie and they and the and then
the central plot is around a second death star
that that in today's market I think would be
just like laughed at and people would say it's
lazy riding and doesn't doesn't make a lot of
sense but I love it I love I love the original
movies I love the prequel trilogy I love the
new movies that were a mess in a lot of ways
I feel like the rise of skywalker was three
movies shoved into two hours and it was pacing
issues and all this stuff but I still love it
and that's I think the magic of star wars is that
star wars doesn't have to be perfect it it
taps into this youthful whimsy this this
this your imagination and things just take over
and and it takes you to this childlike place where
you don't have to be objectively filmmakery when
you watch star wars right and of course I want
the movies to be good and of course you want the
craft to be great but star wars is star wars and
and I'm still a huge fan I'm a fan of what
they're doing on the streaming stuff with
the mandalorian and everything else but for
me star wars is is is is like an old box
and some like an old empty box and me as a dad
I have a seven year old and a and a six month
old and it's interesting like i'll look at an
empty box as an old empty box but a kid looks
at that empty box and it becomes a spaceship or it
becomes a carriage or becomes a tank or it becomes
a castle or becomes all of those in the course
of 25 minutes right I think star wars is like
that old empty box to to some filmmakers and
writers and artists and critics they say that's
that's there's nothing special about that that's
not great I don't get it it's just a box but for
me when I look at star wars I look at at it like
the seven-year-old looking at the empty box no
that's not a box that's that's that's that's an
airplane right that's a spaceship and and it takes
a different lens to to look through it and so I
am I am unabashed of of of my love for ep for for
uh the last jedi right which is the most divisive
star wars film ever ryan johnson's uh episode nine
I loved it I didn't love everything about it but
I loved it I loved I loved the ryze skywalker I
loved it did I love everything about it of course
not they'll have everything about about return
of the jedi of course not but I still love the
movie as a whole I think we've that fandom has
gotten to a point of this deconstructionism of
of they people pick on things and they say all
right this doesn't I mean think about with game of
thrones and game of last season of game of thrones
gave us the battle battle of winterfell gave
us one of the most dramatic interesting coolest
episodes of tv ever filmed ever in history and
the only thing people could talk about the next
day was the coffee cup they left in the scene and
because that's today's thing like that's just the
way the internet is that's just the way twitter
is and people like to deconstruct it and say oh
that's lazy or they dropped they they they fumbled
the landing or whatever they didn't end it right
jj abrams didn't do this right he didn't get this
character right I don't like how ryan johnson did
luke skywalker in this and they nitpick and
nitpick and yeah and things things could be
different things aren't perfect and we don't
love everything but ultimately I I'm i'm a fan
and I love it because it's just it's it's escapism
and and I try honestly as a professional and I
think all of us professionals understand
how difficult it is to make anything and
how like it's a miracle that any movie ever gets
made ever and so i've i've learned to even look at
quote-unquote bad films and still appreciate them
like wow they actually made that even though it's
terrible and I wasn't they didn't necessarily
enjoy it they still made it and the fact that
the fact that that that anything gets made I'm
gonna appreciate it and if I can't do better
than that I try not to criticize it and say
that's garbage or that's lazy or whatever again
I don't love everything about it but ultimately I
look I look at I look at the star wars films and
just with with immense respect for how they've
been able to keep that intellectual property
alive over 60 years or 50 years however long it's
been how much they've been able to scale the brand
how long they've been able to sustain the fan
community and create the culture that they have
to continue to to push artistic boundaries
of what they're doing with the mandalorian
and the volumetric capture stage that they they
built and just the storytelling in the mandalorian
what they're doing what they're doing now with all
the crossover stuff that that one on disney plus
is absolutely incredible you have somebody like
a character like ahsoka tano I'm going to get
star wars nerdy for a second you have you have a
character like ahsoka tano who is a character from
the clone wars animated series that they then pull
into a different animated series star wars rebels
that they then pull into a live action series of
the mandalorian and cast a live action actress and
now gonna spin her off to her own live action
series on disney plus what they're doing from
a trans me in a trans media sense is just really
super interesting and how they revived the star
wars I mean say revive the star it's not like it
was dead but like the way they brought star wars
back in front of culture with baby yoda and now we
know as grosgu but ever like everybody was talking
about baby yoda just the cultural sensation of
baby yoda it's just really smart interesting
choices that they make and especially now start
they just they have something now called star wars
visions where they it's it's it's animated short
films that are all done created in the manga style
so like japanese animation it's all done in with
manga creators telling manga stories in the star
wars universe that are very much catered to
to a completely new market a younger market
a more eastern market where star wars hasn't
been able to really get a foothold as a brand
very much and and and it works and it's good and
it's in it and it's it's powerful storytelling and
so I appreciate them as a fan I appreciate
them as a filmmaker and I appreciate them
as somebody who understands how to
build and sustain intellectual property
like the way they do it is just a master
class on on how to keep an engine like that
running and not just running but thriving in the
midst of multiple multiple decades this really is
a tremendous thing and it all goes back to how
george lucas created and built the whole thing
it's really like he he approached it in a unique
way and they've continued to keep that going do
you think dividing the fandom is by design I don't
think it's by design I think it's I think it's a
byproduct of today's toxic fandom that is just a
thing that goes on now but I think if you were to
criticize lucasfilm for something it's it's with
the movies they they didn't listen to the fandom
not saying that star wars movie the star wars
fans should decide what's in the star wars movies
I'm i'm very much certain that if star
wars fans somehow collectively decided
what the next star wars movie was going to be
it would be terrible there is artistic integrity
and autonomy with the filmmakers but if you look
at somebody like kathleen kennedy kathleen kennedy
is she's an old school filmmakers filmmaker she's
an old school filmmakers producer the way she
used to produce old steven spielberg stuff
and she's very much a filmmaker's producer
she likes to let the filmmakers run and make great
movies and I think part of the misstep of of the
the latest trilogy has been in her letting
the filmmakers kind of run with their own
visions and the lego blocks don't fit together
with the trilogy as well and not really being
in tune with the fandom and and what the fandom
the directions and what the expectations are and
been able to set the expectations with with the
fandom and not that you can please everybody of
course you can't but in some with something
like star wars you just can't approach it
in the way you would in the other movie it's
just a whole other organism that you have to
understand that the fans are part of the process
now and setting expectation and avoiding cognitive
dissonance is a really important thing with
with with understanding how fandoms work so
if I if if if I was if I were to go to the south
of france for a vacation and I get there and it's
overcast and rainy and cold and super
expensive and everybody's grouchy and
not very nice I would come back from that vacation
very upset and frustrated wasn't a great vacation
but if I go to new york city and it's overcast
and cold and rainy and really expensive and
everybody's grouchy guess what that's new york
city like I'm not like I'm not frustrated that
a bit that's the new york city experience the
difference is what's your expectation and so
if I have the expectation it's going to be warm
and bright and sunny and everybody's going to be
sweet and nice and it's the opposite of that
that's where frustration kicks in because of
cognitive dissonance and so managing expectation
of audiences and and letting them know the
direction that we're going and some of the things
we're trying to achieve and and letting them have
a voice and and and making them part of the
conversation and and helping shape some sort of
expectation in their mind not saying plot points
or things like that are big reveals I'm sorry
just general direction that that the franchise is
heading that conversation is super important to
have the fandoms today and that's something that
lucasfilm and kathleen kinley didn't do when it
came to the the the sequel trilogy as they call it
and you and you see now all of a sudden when when
I think everybody was on board for force awakens
but then when ryan johnson did the last jedi
and luke skywalker didn't act like people thought
luke skywalker should act and there were some
choices that were made that were surprising and
didn't go that and then then all of a sudden rises
skywalker went in some different directions
that started to divide the fandom and some
people loved it some people hated it and we they
all couldn't agree and but there wasn't enough
community building I think they just took the
community for granted I think they said as long
as we give them a star wars movie everything will
work out and it just it didn't didn't work but
that being said kathleen kennedy gave us the
mandalorian kathleen kennedy gave us rogue one
which I think is one of the best star wars movies
ever made uh kathleen kennedy has is giving us
she brought in john favreau for for the
mandalorian she's the the book of boba
fett she's overseeing all that like kathleen
kennedy I think has done more good things than
the bad things it just so happens that I think
the misstep was on the biggest stage with the new
trilogy because star wars really is built around
trilogies and that's the legacy of star wars and
so you have to nail those uh they I think we
could fumble some disney plus series and the
fans would gripe about it but you can't fumble
the the the the the trilogy and I'm not saying
it's complete fumble but it wasn't it wasn't as
good as it should have been from a from a from a
trilogy standpoint there should have been she
should have made sure that there was there was
a creative vision and a creative plan that was
that was in place before they even started the
first movie and they were able to see that through
so there would be lego blocks that connected in
the best possible way make sure the community was
on board and understood the direction they were
going to they were going in to avoid the cognitive
dissonance and that didn't happen so that being
said the movie is still wildly successful but
ultimately it created this division the fan base
but the mandalorian kind of brought them all back
together and so even though you may hate last
jedi and I love last jedi we can all high-five on
baby yoda right and so that's been that's been I
think a really good thing for the fandom is is the
mandalorians kind of brought it all back so should
star wars ever make another trilogy oh absolutely
I think they should make 100 more trilogies as
long as the market it will bear it as long as star
wars fans want more star wars movies absolutely
if star wars fans don't want more star wars movies
then the no right the market should decide whether
they should make more or whether they shouldn't
make more I would love I would love more right
and I think we're gonna I think we're gonna we're
gonna see more I think we're gonna see stand-alone
movies and I think we're gonna see trilogies I
think the trilogies will be approached differently
moving forward but patty jenkins is coming
in she she did wonder woman they're both the
wonder woman movies she's doing a rogue squadron
film which should be great kevin feige is going
to be producing a a star wars film taekwontiti
is writing his own star wars movie ryan johnson
from what i've read still has a star wars a
trilogy that they're going to allow him to do
which will probably be super divisive and but I
think if you give him a trilogy that's just his
it works a lot better right especially after this
what we're seeing like his success in knives out
and things like that since then I think has has
changed his star power a little bit to where
I think people trust trust him a little bit more
with it than maybe they did before at least they
should because knives out is great and knives
out too should be great as well I'm a big ryan
johnson friend if you go back to brick and things
like that he's just great but yeah absolutely 100
they should they should continue to make trilogies
they can they should continue to make stand-alone
they should continue to do animation they
should should continue to do live-action series
games uh board games video games novels what
they're doing right now in in the publishing
space is super super super impressive
with what they call the high republic
the high republic part of the universe which is
thousands of years before the prequel trilogy you
go back to the the days where the jedi were like
the the the wild west sheriff's in in sort of this
this really rough part of the galaxy and they
they have coordinated with multiple authors
and multiple comic creators and multiple novelists
and and and they all have have worked out
this tremendously publishing plan where they're
where they're publishing adult novels y a
novels junior novels comic books that all tie in
together to create one big publishing experience
that then is going to spin into a live-action
show for disney plus that's going to be
called the acolyte which is going to be set in the
high republic era which they just also announced
a new video game that's going to be set in the
the knights of the old republic supposedly set in
in a similar time and probably then probably
become the new trilogy I think part of the the
the problem with the sequel trilogy outside of
the lego blocks not fitting together because the
plan wasn't installed is you're dealing with
legacy characters that everybody cares about
luke skywalker and han solo and princess leia
and chewbacca and so all of a sudden everybody
has ideas of how those characters should go
and how and what we should do with them you
can't kill that one but you should kill that one
things like that I think I think any new trilogy
needs to unhitch from those legacy
characters and establish new characters and
new stories in different parts of the galaxy
dealing with different things and so you don't
have all that legacy baggage that's why I
think the mandalorian worked is because it
was it was it didn't have to deal with any of
those legacy characters and we all like okay
we don't have any expectations anymore of of how
luke skywalker's story should end we can all just
enjoy this new ride together and so I think I
think that will probably be the way of a new
trilogy but who knows I mean right I mean who
knows the way it'll go I mean if star wars is
sort of built around this idea of of of pulling
in the crossover of different things and taking
minor characters from the background of this
one scene and a new hope and now we're gonna
make that a major character in the mandalorian
and that's cool for fandoms and there's this very
incestuous incestuous approach to star wars which
maybe is not the best word to use but maybe is the
right word since luke and leia actually kiss
and then you find out their brother and sister
which is all again one of those weird things
that we just love star wars so we overlook
but but it's very very connected and the way
they dine with the way lucas always dynamically
connected all the stuff and the lucasfilm with the
with what they call the story group which is the
the team that oversees the connection between all
the different video games and movies and tv shows
how it all works together so if there will always
be connection and crossover but I think moving
past those legacy characters is gonna is gonna
create it create a more forgiving perspective
on it on a new trilogy that they didn't have with
the sequel trilogy even though they had different
protagonists the fact that luke skywalker was in
there and han solo was in there and jj killed han
solo in force awakens and it just like freaked
so many people out even though I thought it was
a kind of a powerful interesting moment uh in
the movie really just made a lot of people mad
because they love han solo and they think they
should never die star wars fans are weird like
that but it but it's it's I think unhitching from
those characters is really going to be be the way
forward so I really look forward to all the new
content whether whether it's it's it's it's it's
feature films or not what I do think though
is that they'll really manage the windowing of
the release of the films it was getting to a point
where they were they were releasing one a year and
that I think was was difficult especially when you
put in the marvel movies in the mix black panther
and solo were released just a few weeks apart and
there there was some disney cannibalization going
on I think the way forward for star wars movies
is just spacing them out more right especially
if you have the disney plus content and the
publishing content and the the game content
to kind of go between the movies to help continue
to feed the fan base between those big releases
I think that's going to make them more special
and because once you start kind of pumping them
out so much they start to lose their shine a
little bit and especially when it comes to the
interconnected stories it's just it's just they
become less special so windowing I think will help
youtuber mr beast spends four million dollars a
month to make what three or four youtube videos
what do you think about that well I think if the
market watches it and it works for him I think
that's great I mean I think if his if he gets
a return on his investment if we get if the roi
makes sense mazel tov I think that's amazing and
I am presuming that if you look at his numbers
and the subscribers it seems like the market is
bearing out his approach and so so I think it's
great I mean again with with any with any budget
right I mean with with game of thrones spending 10
million dollars for one episode of tv for the lord
of the rings series spending 20 million dollars
for one episode of television or him spending four
million dollars for youtube video if if that if
that creates a positive roi and creates something
that people enjoy and the audience responds to
I think it's awesome I think it's awesome I
don't think it's it's a necessity for everybody
I think the trap is to think is well that means
I have to spend four million dollars on the up
on an episode or or on a youtube video or if I
don't spend four million dollars then I can't do a
good youtube series or I think people get in their
head about that stuff and try to create rules and
things like that but his brand is built around
these super complicated expensive stunts and
crazy things that he does and I think that's that
works for him and obviously he gets results from
that and so I don't want to criticize that I think
it's great and it's working but at the same time
I think other people may can do a very successful
youtube series for zero dollars I don't think it
sets a sets a bright line rule for everybody to
follow but for him he's making it work for sure
have you studied mr beast at all have you sort
of done a deep dive with some of his videos
sure yeah i've i've I don't I don't I wouldn't
say I'm a fan I'm not one of his fans that that
subscribe to his channel and watch all his stuff
but definitely aware of all the different things
that he has done and how he's grown his brand and
diversified his brand in a really interesting way
and the philanthropy he's he's done he does a
lot of really cool philanthropic initiatives
so so definitely aware and appreciative of of
his approach for sure what do you think other
creators can learn from his success I think what
creators can learn from the success of mr beast is
use the platform that you have in front of you use
the platform that is there and for free that you
don't have to wait for cbs to give you a tv deal
to be able to to start building your audience and
this is a refrain that I always go back to is
use the tools that you have attack the market
with what you have and if then if your stuff
is good enough then you're gonna start building
building that audience out and so that's what I
love about mr beast is is is he just used what was
in front of him whether it's youtube whether it's
twitch whether it's tick tock whatever it is use
the tools that you have also you look at volume
I think mr beast he he produces a lot of content
and it's not just one thing every now and then
like it's it's his big stunt prank things uh
are windowed but there's a lot of content that
comes through of the variety of his channels
because he doesn't just have one channel he
has multiple channels right and so basically
he's his own network if you look at it in the
traditional sense and so volume of content in a
commoditized market is a strategy that's super
super important if you only do one thing every
now and then in a commoditized market there's so
much new content that hits the market your one
thing just disappears because there's too much
stuff that that sort of buries it right so you
have to be able to take a volume based strategy to
be able to compete in in a commoditized market and
that's what mr beast is doing lots of content on
the platforms that are that are available to him
that the platforms that that that he's on and
what I like about him is is is diversification
is is he has different channels and different
types of things he tries different formats it's
not just a one-trick pony it's he's willing to try
new and different things on different platforms in
different styles and different formats and genres
and and really diversify the brand and if you look
at if you listen if you read warren buffett and or
listen to warren buffett which I don't know if mr
b's listen to warren buffett or not but warren
buffett says he never he never suggests that
investors invest into companies that that operate
and commoditize markets because it's just too this
is just too difficult for them to compete unless
they have the right strategy of competing in the
commoditized market which he says is creating
a branded ecosystem based on diversification
diversification and volume and synergy is your
stuff tied together are you creating lots of
stuff and are you diversifying the type of stuff
that you're creating and the platforms that you're
creating on and if you look at what mr beast is
doing he's really doing a great job of the synergy
of volume and diversification and so I think
that's why he's able to to to compete in the
commodities market which is that's the big
takeaway that as a filmmaker for me is that's
what I learned from from him he's not waiting on
anybody to give him permission to create his stuff
and now that he's created it himself on
this platform guess what he owns the brand
nobody owns that else owns his brand and if
cbs or abc or amazon or netflix or whoever
decides to come and say hey we want to do a whole
mr beast movie or a mr beast cartoon or a mr beast
series he's now in a leveraged position to where
he will decide uh how how that deal will play out
because he owns his own brand look what happened
with with joe rogan and spotify like he did a 500
million dollar deal with spotify for his podcast
because he owned his podcast because he launched
his podcast before he got getting involved with
spotify and grew his own audience and that's
that's what I love about mr beast is mr beast owns
this brand it's his he doesn't have any any uh
of these of these studios or networks divvying up
the rights or or or controlling him or dictating
the content like he's in the driver's seat of
his brand which as a as a creator I I'm always
going to root for and I'm impressed by and so
that I'm a fan of that and that's why I think
filmmakers can learn from him as well is own your
brand use the tools that you have in front of you
diversify and attack the market with volume he's
doing all those things and it's and it's working
for him it's playing out in the market what do you
think about mr b's purchasing 100 acres of land
and building a 10 million dollar studio it's 23. I
think it's I think it's amazing I mean I think if
you look at if you look at what tyler perry did if
you look at what robert rodriguez's of what he did
he's following in those footsteps as a youtuber
which is amazing and it the more you could
disintermediate other people that control your
stuff and control your content or control the
way you produce the content or or how you produce
the content when you produce the content where
you produce content the more that you can just own
your own brand in every way that's always going to
be better right and it's an asset I mean it's it's
he's now a real estate magnet right like it's it's
the fact that I mean that gives that's
that's valuable that's financially valuable
but the fact that he's creating his own studios
is it just shows nobody's going to tell him
how to create window create and why to create so
if you're using youtube studios there's strings
attached if you use as well there should
be because they're it's youtube studios
right if somebody's coming to my studio or your
studio of course there's you're gonna tell me
how I should act I should tell you how you should
act and how you there's always going to be strings
attached and which means ultimately you don't
really own your stuff yeah I mean it's like it's
like moving into a neighborhood with a with with
with a really aggressive hoa right the fact that
if you can't let your lawn grow more than six
inches high else you start getting fines do you
really own your lawn at that point I mean
there's like an interesting like for me I
don't like that I don't like people telling me
how like when I need to cut my grass or I can't
how quickly I need to remove my trash cans from
the curb before I get the ticket I don't like
that right I feel like these are my trash cans
this is my lawn I should be able to do with what
I want right I feel like that's the american
way and that's and so I love the fact that
an independent creator doesn't have to go to some
giant conglomerate to be able to make the stuff
and this is a refrain that I always go back to
yeah is is how does the how does the filmmaker
not wait for permission from a giant multi-billion
dollar international conglomerate uh to to say you
can you can create the stuff that's in your heart
how do you just go ahead and do it yourself and by
creating his own production facilities just like
tyler perry just like robert rodriguez just like
im not shyamalan just just like any of these
independent creators that go and do their own
thing he's doing that and he's gonna he's gonna
have his destiny in his own hands that doesn't
preclude him from working with any of these other
people but it just puts him in more of a leveraged
position because he just has more ownership over
everything literally has more ownership over the
whole thing we think it's only a matter of time
before mr beast will make a movie and it'll gross
100 million dollars plus what do you think
about that oh yeah I'm certain of it I think
he will be able to continue to grow the
brand to the point where if there's demand
for a feature film or or for something like that
or even a tv series of course I mean you look at
something another youtube break out the hot ones
which was an interview show on youtube that was
wildly popular and it was a very basic concept
where this guy he interviews a famous person
and they eat hot wings as they as they as they
interview and the hot wings get hotter as they go
right super clever concept right that just that
slowly built a very massive audience that 100
million people subscribed to the channel and
eventually then he gets his own real reality
show and own real on actual tv he now has an
interview show and he gets called up to the major
leagues because that's usually the way it goes
but he estab but he owns the brand he established
it first so that typically is is the the the
path that that that brands go in now does that
does that necessarily mean that he'll
have to do it no I think he I obviously
I don't think he would need to do it for any
financial benefit necessarily I don't think
at this point he's super motivated by money
because he's been very financially successful
which I think is a good thing so I think mr
beast will look at look at the options of
I don't have to do it for money so the reasons
i'll do it is it are the reasons that will help
grow the brand feed the fan base in the right
organic way that makes sense for the brand where
people I think where where brands get off is is
it off track is when they do it for a money grab
and it it's not coherent to the brand and it
doesn't feel like it's contextual in in in
in a in a way that that adds value to the
fan base it just feels like a sellout payday
right and sometimes it can feel like that but I
think with mr beast taking ownership the brand
in the way that he's done and been able to amass
the serious wealth that he's been able to amass
with the brand that the motivation won't be money
it'll be something else and doesn't mean it's
going to be great this doesn't mean it's going
to work but I do think he'll probably follow that
path you look at something a board game that was
that was created called throw throw burrito is and
exploding kittens and there was there's there's
something that that created these indie board
games on kickstarter and they got to be super
popular and now they're being turned into cartoons
and and tv shows and movies and things like
that because that's the way the entertainment
industry works right is eventually you get you
get that big break for the big platforms I think
mr beast will will do something non-traditional
I think maybe mr beast because he has a community
may not go to paramount pictures to make the
mr beast movie or maybe even not even netflix
I think maybe mr beast does something very
non-traditional like like launching a movie
as an nft on the blockchain and pulling
the community in participation of of
of the movie through the nft so they could
actually now participate as as equity partners
in the exploitation of the film and try something
different because there's no downside for him to
try that and there's no reason he has to go to
traditional Hollywood I think just the the fact
that he's been so new media with everything and
so outside the quote-unquote system of Hollywood
I I would guess that before he would go to a
universal pictures or or or paramount pictures or
disney or something like that or nickelodeon
I think it would be I think you would explore
something non-traditional like launching it on the
blockchain which I think would be great because
the thing that makes nfts work is community
having an established community that can jump in
and purchase the nft purchase the tokens that
then monetizes the the product the movie or
whatever it is monetizes the whole project and
then gives them that profit participation and a
stake in the actual brand that where nfts fail
is a lack of community is is they launched nft
and there's nobody nobody there to buy them
because they haven't built community first the
nfts that are really working are the ones that
have community first then launch the nft and so
the fact that mr beast has amassed so many
subscribers amass this huge community I would I
would be shocked if if he didn't explore something
like an nft to be able to launch a series or
launch a movie and you're already seeing craters
kind of moving into that so it's not completely
like untested waters but I would I would guess
that there would be some sort of willingness to
do something non-traditional outside the system as
a way to create that movie or create that tv show
sorry guys this entire theory doesn't hold water
at all the massive breakthrough success of the mcu
has done almost nothing on all caps to increase
the sales of marble comics as a matter of fact
the books are struggling big time conversely
iron man was a lesser known marvel hero when
his movie dropped and the guardians of
the galaxy were mostly obscure comic book
d-listers both suggesting that it wasn't comic
readers that made the movies succeed it was also
the quality of the marvel movies as movies
that made people care so yeah go ahead and
try to launch a comic and or novel and or video
game while you simultaneously meet the herculean
task of shooting and promoting an indie movie good
luck there you will need it sure yeah absolutely
I think I think if you pull that apart a little
bit there's a couple interesting things that that
that I would respond to because I want to have
empathy for that comment and the the comments
interesting but i'll take the middle comment there
first about the herculean task of trying to do it
simultaneous of a movie that's crazy you should
never try to be doing it simultaneous to the film
I would never advocate you trying to create a
comic book while you're trying to make a movie
that's crazy you should never do that you should
you you should be creating the comic book well
before you ever make the movie for sure like yeah
you can't be you can't be anybody that's ever
made a movie knows how all-encompassing it is to
make a movie you can't do anything you can barely
feed yourself and pay your bills and take your
dogs on the walk while you're trying to like at
the same time of making a movie like your whole
life stops just so you can do it there's no
way you're going to be able to be managing the
production of a mobile game and the production
of an album and the and the production of a comic
book while you're making a movie so so I would 100
agree with the comment about that don't do it
let's just avoid that altogether now that doesn't
mean you shouldn't make a comic book and a movie
let's just make him at different times right so
now before you ever make the movie let's make the
comic book to then grow the audience in a way that
that establishes pre-awareness in the market I
mean think about this think about think about you
when you make a movie that's not based on let's
just say you find the financing let's just say
hypothetically you find magical financing your
grandma leaves you a hundred thousand dollars
in her will so that you can make your your
movie so you make a hundred thousand dollar
feature film which is awesome right you have
the financing to do it if it's unbranded content
when you release the movie you're releasing it
to to no fans by definition there aren't any
fans because this has never been released in the
market before it's unbranded content you haven't
you haven't pushed it out at all so there isn't
anyone who loves it yet and it could be great I'm
not saying it's not great no one knows about
it yet because the movie's not out yet right
so you're releasing it into the market with no
fans just hoping and praying that everybody shows
up on opening weekend so we can consider this a
success right so now look at look at the other the
the other path is we know that that it's it's that
any movie one when you start production it's gonna
be two years before that movie ever sees a lot
of day but even even if you go through the the
normal pre-production principle photography
post-production distribution process but let's
say even before you get to that to to to the
production standpoint leading up to it right
you go ahead and establish the market say with a
comic book or podcast let's just say podcast right
so you say you launch the podcast ideally
maybe podcast and comic book right but let's
just stick with one let's say let's say podcast
if you have 10 000 people who love your podcast
that is connected narratively to the movie that
you will you will be releasing in the future
right so you you you open the brand up to 10
000 people who love the narrative universe the
story the characters the concept like they're
in it right and then and now they're your fans
they're in your brand they're supportive
because we love this podcast it's awesome
we're fans of this whole thing when you make
your movie and you release your movie guess
what you're doing you're gonna release the movie
and there's ten 000 fans that already love it
they already love it they may not love the
movie yet but they love the brand and releasing
a movie to 10 000 fans who already love it
is better than releasing a movie to no fans
that to no fans right like that like that that
that's the punch line is it's of course like think
about this if I if I if I release if I release a
podcast and I and I create 10 000 fans and then I
release a novel I release that novel into a market
that's warm it's a warm market not a cold market
now i've warmed the market with ten thousand fans
now there's ten thousand fans that can buy my book
and then let's say I get twenty bucks per book do
the math ten thousand times twenty that equals out
to a profit potential as opposed to not doing
anything first and then just releasing my novel
into the market to zero fans does that does that
mean that there's no way for me to make money of
course not there's people that do that make money
in books all the time but it's a harder road
to release to no fans than it is to release to
10 000 fans it's reductive thinking you almost
have to make yourself a little bit dumber to use
common sense for that to make sense I feel like
we're overthinking it like of course it's better
to have 10 000 fans already loving your stuff when
you release your movie of course of course right
I mean it just it just it just it just makes sense
and so so whatever way you can establish
the community of fans any community of fans
that love your brand and love your intellectual
property ahead of the release of the movie then
when you release that movie you're going
to increase your chances for success
does it guarantee success of course not but
you have a higher chance of success than if you
release that same movie into a cold market that's
the punchline now then if you add in the fact that
there's probably not you you've minimized your
chance of gaining investment from a private
equity investor or studio because it's unbranded
content right like like that that's a whole other
conversation that just to get the financing you
need to have that market presence by and large
that comes by way of attachment or by by brand
awareness of the intellectual property right
but so so there's lots of reasons you need to
do this but I completely agree you shouldn't do
at the same time it'll make you go crazy right
that's that it'll make your marriage fall apart
and make you grow a crazy beard and make you
stressed out like it's just it's bad news like
you shouldn't you should not try to juggle all
the like the filmmaking is so crazy difficult we
all know being on set it's just too difficult to
do all those things at the same time right spread
them out warm the market then release the movie
so that's the middle comment the second thing
i'll address about the comment really is the first
part of the comment where the the commenter said
that the the mcu didn't boost sales of marvel
comics and and I would agree with that as well
I would I would absolutely I'm agreeing with the
commenter more than I'm disagreeing with commenter
and because there's a narrative reason for that
is is when they when kevin feige launched the
mcu it was a different canon than the comics and
so canon is sort of the official narrative that
goes along with a franchise or an intellectual
property and so what is the official story
and there were I mean there was what 70 years
or of of of marvel comic narrative that had been
going on forever and when they started the mcu
they wanted to start a new canon because that
was way too much complexity way too much
baggage way too much story to deal with
adequately it just confines the filmmakers
too much right because because there's
the only way you can make this movie is you if
you go read 3000 comic books that doesn't become
an attractive entry point for filmmaker to want
to do right so so it's just too much baggage and
so they they they said the mcu will be a special
canon it's going to be a new canon that the comic
books will still be the thing will be a thing and
they'll still have their own canon and they'll
have their own stories that will continue but
we're going to set up a new completely fresh
consistent canon that starts with the mcu that
won't just be the movies they actually have a line
of comic books that that is a special mcu line of
comic books that's tied in with the mcu that goes
along with the mcu but those comic books aren't
part of the the the legacy marvel comic books
that that that that are out there and so yeah of
course when when when when the iron man movies and
the avengers movies and all these movies came
out they didn't boost sales of the comic books
because the comic books didn't extend the story
of the movies and so from a transmedia perspective
the incentive for the audience to migrate to
a different platform is that the the story in
the different platform is going to give them more
insight and more narrative and more payoff of the
thing that they love and so if they were to learn
more about this these movies and the tv shows and
things like that by going through the comic books
maybe they would have but because all marvel fans
knew that with new marvel fans or even legacy fans
that there was a disconnected cannon there was no
incentive for them to go check out the check out
the comic books and and I don't think kevin feige
at marvel necessarily intended for these things
to to to for the the comic book sales to spike
so that's why they didn't spike they broke the
cannon and there was never a business objective
or a creative objective of kevin feige who's
over the puppet master of the mcu and so so
so so of course of course those didn't spike now
does that mean see this is we don't want to we
don't want to conflate that to say well that means
comic books connected with with movies don't work
and there's no reason because they no it they can
make it work like if the canon would be consistent
with with the film and television and they work
together now all then all of a sudden they begin
to feed each other you look at the the difference
in how marvel treated the legacy the the legacy
comics in with marvel and compare that to how
lucasfilm deals with the comic books in star
wars it's very different and so all of a sudden
you you watch the sequel trilogy and you have
kylo ren who is who is the head of the knights of
wren and in the movies the knights of ren aren't
really explained like who they are and how how he
got roped in with those with that crew seemed just
like it's a kid that kind of got involved with
some bad friends that took him in a bad direction
they sort of allude to it so you can still enjoy
the movie without all that backstory knowledge
right but they revealed who the knights of ren
are what happened to to ben solo after he left
luke skywalker's jedi academy and kind of went off
on his own and they they tell that complete story
in comic books and so now the comic books is
is now extending the film franchise the trilogy
and now there's synergy between the two
things and so now obviously we have film
fans who are migrating over to the comic
book does everybody migrate of course not
everybody migrates right but you get your the
the comic books do absolutely benefit from
the migration of a certain percentage of the
film fans that want to dig deeper and know more
or there are some people that haven't seen
the movies that are into the comic books so
then find the entry point in the comic books and
then find their way over to the movies because
they are now interested in the knights of ren and
that's part of the movies and so it can flow both
ways right so so you absolutely see spikes
in sales when there's intentional narrative
synergy what I call additive comprehension
between the works right but that's an intention
that needs to be made from a business perspective
a business model perspective and also a narrative
intention that goes along with that you got to tie
these stories together in a very intentional way
to have that happen if you don't intend it from a
business perspective and you don't intentionally
tie these stories together narratively of
course you'll never see a spike but that doesn't
that doesn't lead you to a conclusion of you
should never have a comic book right like like
that that's it's a complete like it depends on how
you execute the comic book and how you and how you
execute it in the context where it goes along
with the film it's the contextual information
that you kind of need to be able to make
that work right so so so absolutely uh
the the the commenter is right in the analysis
but I think the conclusion that's inferred
from that analysis is is incorrect you just
don't want to conflate it and apply it to oh
never you need to do a comic book comic books are
dumb like you don't need to get to that conclusion
let's just do it in the right way if you intend it
if you intend to spike that means you have to do
it the right way that's all that means they didn't
star wars actually did this with with what they
called the extended universe which they when when
lucasfilm or when lucasfilm was sold to disney
they had been writing novels and comic books and
especially novels for 20 years and there were only
hundreds of novels and video games and comic books
all the stuff that disney inherited by way of the
purchase not just the original film trilogy of the
prequel trilogy there were there were hundreds and
hundreds of of of licensed works that were created
and it was too much for lucas or for disney to
figure out so they decannonized all that stuff
and said this isn't an official story anymore
from from at this point on we're creating new
canon we're disconnecting from this other stuff
right so so so in the same way the new
stuff that they've released doesn't spike
the sales of all that extended universe stuff
that that that's older because there's a narrative
disconnect right and it's not their business
intention so of course whenever you have that
disconnect it's not gonna it's not gonna achieve
that result and I don't think they're disappointed
in it because they never intended to do that in
the first place and the last part of the comment
is like talked about luck with any luck this
would have of course you listen nothing's ever
guaranteed everything like whether it's luck or
kismet or or fate or destiny whatever it is like
of course there's always going to be an element
of of right place right time uh what do you
call it luck we call it just whatever you call it
karma I don't know there's there's something that
that this x factor that has to happen for things
to be to pop off to be successful no if anybody
ever tells you that there's a guaranteed way or a
guaranteed model of success in the film industry
or the creative industry or creative content
production that there's a guaranteed methodology
of like the silver bullet do this every time and
it's going to pop and be amazing and be huge if
anybody ever says that you need to you need to
run the opposite direction because it's not true
it all you can have the the best laid
plans you can have the best stories
the best ideas the best business model
and sometimes it just doesn't work for
a thousand different reasons and it's not because
your business model is bad and it's not because
your idea was bad or you're like just sometimes it
doesn't work and it's weird and it's just like and
or sometimes culturally something it happens in it
and something pops off in a just right place right
time the right idea and who knew that baby yoda
would blow up the way baby yoda did like like it
was that luck was that right place right time what
like what was it I don't know and so so yeah like
this anything that I say is is is not
silver bullet I think anybody that writes
a screenwriting book of like this is the way to
stretch your screen but that's not a guaran if
you use the structure it's guaranteed that
your screenplay is going to sell or be good
of course not of course you need some element
of quote-unquote luck in addition to best laid
plans and and and approaches that increase your
chances right that's all I'm saying is if you
if you use a multi-platform approach to attack
the market in as many ways possible to use all the
tools and toolbox generate audience have a market
presence for your intellectual property be able to
to to create an ecosystem that feeds itself in a
commoditized market before you get to the big st
the big film and television investment heavy
things that are so risky for people and they
don't want to lose their jobs because they don't
want to take the risk if you just do that stuff it
doesn't guarantee you selling anything it doesn't
guarantee you succeeding in anything it increases
your chances from from a from a sp with a sports
analogy if if if you just take an unbranded
piece of content and you just release it into the
market and you try to sell the script you try to
you just you just you just put it out there right
it's like it's like with the football analogy it's
like being back on your own one yard line throwing
a hell mary all the way down the field right
that's hard like it's rare that that works it's
very difficult right and does does every now
and then does does it work for somebody of course
and that's the trap you see somebody on the other
a few feet down from you say oh they completed
their pass that means I can complete my pass which
is true technically it's true but you may spend
20 years trying to throw that same hail mary down
the field and never and it just doesn't work and
that's not your fault and it's just not doesn't
mean you're a bad person or a bad creative it just
didn't work so what I say is let's run a few plays
to move down the field a little bit let's
do the five yard podcast let's do the 15
yard comic book let's do the seven yard board
game right and let's get to the point to where
we're at the 50 yard line and throw the hail mary
because everything in the film industry is going
to be a hail mary everything even the studios with
the stuff that they do is going to be hail mary's
nothing's guaranteed right but every especially
for independent filmmakers everything that we
make is going to be a hail mary so but I
would rather throw the hell mary from the 50
than my own one that's all I'm saying it increases
your odds increases your chances but you do have
that have to have that little piece of magic you
have to have that little piece of magic or luck or
whatever you call it in order for these things
to work and that's that's the cool thing about
the industry right you just there's it's not
ones and zeros like the matrix there's there's
something else that that that comes in to all the
stuff that you make and and and it makes something
come alive and that's cool and that's interesting
and that's what makes it exciting so so I agree
with almost every single thing in that comment
which is which is but maybe I have a different
perspective or a different angle in it and sorry
for those of us who don't know football what is
the definition of that type of past oh okay yeah
sorry I forget no that's okay yeah so so hail mary
is is uh just it's usually your last resort you're
way far back on the other end of the field and you
just like throw it way up in the air and just hope
that somebody catches it right it's not really a a
well-designed tactical play it's it's the hail
mary let's just hope and pray that something
happens and it works right like that's that's
that's the hail mary and it usually only happens
when teams are getting ready to lose and they're
running out of time and there's nothing else
to do except throw it really far down the field
really high in the air and just see what happens
what can filmmakers learn from the pixar theory
I think what filmmakers can learn from the pixar
theory is is that just how fans think and for
people that don't know the the pixar theory the
pixel theory is the unofficial fan theory that
all the pixar movies exist in one narrative
universe and they're all connected in crazy ways
where pixar the official line from pixar is that
all these things are disconnected right and they
don't have anything to do with each other but fans
they've constructed their own crazy interconnected
universe and so what what filmmakers can learn
from that is that innately fans love connection
they love things to cross over they love the
the one story that they love to connect with the
other story that they love they desire this and
if they don't see a connection they will
figure out how there is a connection and
if you look at fan theaters not just the picture
theory but just like any fan theories there are
are fun and interesting but it shows that the the
psychology and the mentality of the modern fandom
that they crave connection you look at something
like with the fact that if you watch episode one
of star wars in the galactic senate scene there's
a there's a pod of aliens that are all ets
which means wait a minute that's e-t is is in
the star wars universe which and so now these
things are connected in a really interesting way
which then if you then go watch et that makes
that that that explains why e.t reacts to the
kid in the yoda mask not because he's an alien
but the reason he reacts to the yoda
mask is because he's he knows yoda
because he's from the star wars universe which
means if when et makes the bicycle fly at the end
of the movie he's not using weird alien magic
he's using the force which means et's a jedi
which is awesome and fans will work all that
stuff out and which is ridiculous but it's fun
but it's ridiculous but what it shows so we
shouldn't discard that as filmmakers say oh that's
just a crazy fan theory no no like look at why
the fans doing that and figure out like what's the
mentality and what's the psychology behind that
they crave connection you think about this think
about imminent shyamalan what people haven't been
excited about in the night shyamalan in 15 years
right but then when he made when he made split
right which was a solid movie and it was good
but the best part of split was at the end when
they were revealed the connection to unbreakable
and that's when people said oh my god I'm
not shyamalan he's back he imagined is
his filmmaking didn't necessarily improve he
started connecting his stories and the fans got
excited about it so then you had unbreakable then
he connected it with split and then they converged
those things into into glass and he created his
own little connected universe out of those three
films which fans loved and it really revived his
career that one decision to connect those films
revived his whole career in a great way right
kevin smith you look back kevin smith who broke in
with with the glut of independent filmmakers that
broke into the 90s the the thing that separated
him from all those other filmmakers is the fact
that he started connecting interconnecting all
his movies his clerks connected the mall rats was
collected connected chasing amy which connected
to jay and silent bob and they all existed in in
this little town in jersey and they they they they
referred to the different the the plot points of
the different movies in a really interesting way
but still in the way that they could still stand
alone but there was obvious there was a connection
that separated him from all those other filmmakers
and and was able to he created a community
around his intellectual property that
other filmmakers weren't able to do
because they didn't connect not and listen I
think we could probably I think kevin smith
would agree that he's not necessarily the best
filmmaker of all those filmmakers that broke
broke in in the 90s right but he was
able to build just such a rabidly
devout community because the fans were excited
about the connections between the stories and so
so for me the pixar theory is all about the fans
and the way they think it's not about I mean it's
interesting to think about of like well the witch
the witch and brave is actually the little girl
in monsters inc and because when you when
you see the witch's cabin there's a there's
a there's an etching of mike wazowski and sully
in the wood carving of the of the wall which
which which then I think the theory says uh after
after cele leaves boo at the end of monsters inc
she spends the rest of her life searching for
him and uses the magic of the doors to ultimately
like get trapped in ancient scotland but she she
understands how to use the magic of the doors
to then turn people into bears and the reason she
turns them into bears is she's trying to recreate
sully in her own life will always without with
tragic results and it's like however the story
goes right or the fact that I think that the pixar
series theory says that if you watch the end of
frozen uh rapunzel and the dude that rapunzel
flynn that do the rapunzel mary's they're at
elsa's coronation which means they're connected
which then the the the theory said that elsa's
parents died in a in a ship sinking accident and
but they actually didn't die the ship sank they
actually made it to a deserted island restarted
their lives had a son on the island who was tarzan
and then the ship that sank was the ship that the
little mermaid explores at the beginning of the
little mermaid when she finds the fork and all
that stuff and they create all this connection
and that's fun right but that's not the big
takeaway the big takeaway is what are they doing
like think of that think about what they're doing
they're they're working hard to create connection
that's what they want they love it they that
excites them right connection excite that this
is why it's why people this is the brilliance of
the mcu this is the burnings of what what what
of what's going on with the mandalorian this is
this is this is this is what this is even in video
games with things like kingdom hearts and and
when can when you throw uh a crossover character
into a mortal kombat game we love crossover and
connection you look at chicago fire chicago med
chicago pd all the biggest like raiding ratings
events in tv are those crossover events right
as a kid I loved it when scooby-doo crossed over
with batman and robin and the the globetrotters
and there was the connection like we the fans
always loved that stuff and it's always played out
which makes me wonder why would a filmmaker ever
make things without connections to other things
if you do you're going against the psychology of
the audience because the pixar theory for first
and foremost shows the mindset of the modern fan
which means when you create something and you're
not connecting anything you're you're you're
going against the expectation the audience and
ultimately that's uh I think if you if you create
things understanding your audience and understand
how they think and what motivates them and what
they like if you read up on this philosophy called
phenomenology phenomenology the philosophy of of
the the highest the the the most art the greatest
artistic achievement of the artist is not the
art itself it's the experience that you create
between the audience and the art the experience
is the is the achievement not the art
but the only way to get the experience is to
understand what the audience wants and how to
create that experience with the art and it's the
combination that creates the experience so so you
have to understand the psychology of the audience
if you want to create that magical experience and
the pixar theory gives us a very clear
window into how the audience thinks
so is that why people love crime podcasts or
puzzles because we're connecting we're trying to
connect of course I think it's just how we that's
how we operate this that's how we work the how our
brains work right and so we're always trying to
connect pieces and and our brain our brain does it
for us sometimes subconsciously just how we are we
like we like these interesting connections and it
plays out in entertainment whether it's superhero
stuff whether it's what the walking dead has been
doing with crossing over all their shows whether
what what hannah barbara did way back in the day
whatever nbc does like crossover events has been
a staple of modern entertainment for decades so
this isn't a new thing it's always worked right
it's working even more now in a sort of a modern
multi-platform transmedia market but this isn't
sort of a new development it's always worked
right so I think understanding as a filmmaker
understanding the psychology of the audience
and creating content that connects with other
content it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna again
just increase your chances for your entertainment
to really to really succeed in today's market.
What do you like about this video?